micah good morning brother how are we
doing doing well how are you
outstanding outstanding so how can i
help you this morning
so when i was 18 my dad
left our family and moved in with his
mistress
um at that point i kind of told him
that i she wasn't part of my life but
his life and i had nothing to do with
her
and fast forward to the to today i'm 21
and he texts me and my brother that they
are now getting married and he's kind of
been forcing
upon us that she's a part of his life
now in order to be with him
we need to meet her and i still haven't
met her and have been recently being
conflicted
on if i'm doing all i can as far as
even accepting him and who he is and
also sharing the love of christ
and to um his situation
and if i'm in the wrong or not for still
holding
what i said before not meeting her hmm
so why haven't you met her yet
um so one i never had the opportunity
like at the very first of it
um it just wasn't a thing and i was kind
of oblivious to the affair
you're 21 now so why haven't you reached
out just to meet her now
yeah why haven't you reached out in the
last year too and this isn't a judgment
question this is just me
digging in why haven't you just decided
hey i need to meet this lady she's been
with my dad for three years now
part of it from what i've heard of other
people
and that have known her in the past i
know i probably shouldn't
yeah i don't care what other people say
why haven't you reached out
you're 21 you can drink and drive that
sounded bad
you can drink period you can drive
period you can buy guns period
why haven't you why haven't you reached
out to her you're an adult now
i've just always had an
uncomfortableness about it okay
i've never had been out of peace how has
your relationship with your mom changed
um we have grown a whole lot closer
okay um i've stayed she's had some
medical issues
from all the stress and stuff and
there's been a lot of
yeah supporting her and her supporting
the family
so your dad's getting married soon and
you're in this
weird spot do you still talk to him
outside of this outside of his recent
text message which is how children
communicate with one another by the way
it's i would say it's embarrassing and
it's frustrating that your grown father
chose to
drop this on you via text message but
that's for
that's for another show um how has your
relationship with him been
outside of him leaving your mom and
finding somebody new do y'all talk
regularly do you talk on the phone do
y'all have lunch together how does that
how do y'all interact
um we interact on the phone and with
lunch
it's very sporadic um because sometimes
it really can be
it's just easier to love him from a
distance
sure and let him reach out to me um
going to school working
and when i have too much contact with
him or i'm talking with him
um regularly there's a lot of arguments
that go back to
needing to meet her and him justifying
all of his decisions
and me you know saying that
i don't agree here and stuff and him
just trying to prove why he's writing
everything and how he's still in god's
will
and talking about you know
trying to correct me as a christian too
so let's let's
put mom down and let's put dad down and
i want to take you in a spaceship and
let's go up 30 thousand feet
above this situation okay okay so
there's a guy
who made your mom cry he hurt your mom
right when you're an 18 year old young
man
he hurt your mom and he's continued to
hurt your mom for the last three years
so you're going to have a natural
built-in
extended middle finger to the guy that
hurts your mom that's natural and that's
normal
okay and you love
this guy called your dad and
in whatever weird way it sounds like
he's still
in some broken fumbly way loves you
and still tries to connect with you and
still tries to reach out he's still
desperate for your affirmation
right he still wants you to make sure
this is all okay for him
because he's still conflicted but he's
still your dad
and you still love your dad and it's
okay to still love your dad even if he
hurt you
and so what you need to do is this your
dad
is a grown man of his own and he's
allowed to do whatever he wants to do
right wrong or indifferent
what i will tell you is every marriage
has things that goes on behind closed
doors that are hard and
ugly and messy and challenging
and you will probably never fully get to
the bottom of what was in your dad's
heart what was in your mom's heart what
20 years or 30 or 40 years of them being
married was like you'll never know
you'll also never come around to the
fact that what your dad did was okay
right that's never gonna be something
you make peace with
and so what you've got to do is put down
your thoughts about what my dad's doing
what his
new wife is doing you get all that down
and you have to make decisions grown-up
adult decisions
for you micah
you've got to decide who you're going to
be and what character is going to look
like for you
and so less about how can i should i do
this
for him and should i be it are you going
to be a guy
and these aren't judgment questions
again i'm just asking questions to for
you to think through these
this is going to be a loyalty issue
about you and your mom can i love my dad
and still love my mom
is it am i going to be abandoning her am
i going to be being disloyal to her if i
go to this wedding
if i go meet this other lady right um
are you going to be disloyal and abandon
your dad
who walked away from you guys right are
you going to abandon your dad if you
never decide to meet her
you've got to own the legacy of these
conversations these are character
decisions for you my man
and so when i want to ask you put your
dad's stuff down put your mom stuff down
what do you want to do micah
okay no i'm asking you
what do you want to do um
i i want a relationship with my father
so he has told you you can have a
relationship with me in one way and one
way only and that's if you
fully accept this new woman and you meet
her and you make her a part of your life
too because you don't get me without her
and he's a grown-up and he's drawn that
boundary you may think that boundaries
nuts
it may be immoral it may be violates
your faith
like your religious codes but that's the
boundary he drew
and your mom may have drawn a boundary
which is if you loved me
you will never talk to that woman and
now you're a 22 year old man
stuck in the middle of other people's
boundaries which is where we all find
ourselves all the time so i'm asking you
not what about him what do you want to
do
um
all right i want to have
my own life apart
a part of immorality and
being able to raise my own family the
way
that i see the lord is leading me to
raise them
okay can you be in contact and in
relationship with people who choose
different values than you
or does that mean they're you're done
with them
no i can't you can't what
i can be in contact with you you can
okay
yeah so my question to you and you're
telling this to everyone who's listening
to this podcast which may be like 18
people
if we're being honest right um
will you go to that wedding or are you
going to tell your dad
i simply can't accept your new wife i
can't accept that i still love you as my
dad
but i can't be a part of that wedding or
are you gonna go to the wedding and say
dad i think this whole thing's a mess
and tell his new wife you are
my dad's new wife i don't like how any
of this happened i'm going to respect
you as a person
um i don't approve of this i don't like
this but this is the life that
the cards i've been dealt and you're
going to go to your mom and say mom
you're my mom and i love you and dad's
my dad and i love him
however crooked and messy this whole
thing has gotten i'm going to love you
both the best i can
which one of those sounds right in your
heart
probably going to the wedding and
talking about how it's not right but i'm
still loving both of them
okay what's your mom gonna say about
that conversation
she's gonna be in support of it okay
do you feel at peace with moving on
towards honoring relationships even if
you don't buy in
what's going on behind closed doors even
if your values on the front end say i
don't like this
are you at peace with that yes i am
man a whole lot more i usually don't
think i do a lot of good on this thing
but i think we we got somewhere today
micah way to go man
hey here's the thing i do too thank you
listen you're 21
and i want to just give you some really
great slash not great news
this is the rest of your life
i really want this job but it's in this
city
i really want to marry this person
but they want to live in this town
i want to have six kids they want to
have two
i want to have dogs they want to have
cat this is the rest of your life
i want to go to this church you know she
wants to go to that church
i want to have this kind of friend he
doesn't want to
that's the rest of your life and so what
often we get sucked into is
how can i help this person especially
with our parents
kids get really round up in how can i
make my dad feel okay
how can i stand my ground hold my values
be my own person and also make sure my
dad's feeling okay
and so if you can have this hard
conversation with yourself
with your faith values with your mom
with your dad if you can start having
these hard conversations now brother
micah
the rest of your life is going to look
very different because you're going to
get to own
what you want what your boundaries are
what your values are
and then you're going to own those hard
conversations done in dignity and with
respect and with love
you're not going to be ugly to his new
wife if you choose to meet her
you're going to say hi you're a person
you came into this situation it's a mess
i would have preferred this not be this
way but you're a human i'm going to
treat you with dignity and honor
i'm going to be kind to you and i'm not
going to be disrespectful i'm not going
to become
the guy that i watched my dad become and
i'm going to talk to my mom and be
honest with her and that's going to let
you live your life with dignity and with
respect
hold your values and if your values end
up being you know what i'm not going to
sweating i cannot support anything about
this i think it's wrong
it violates every part of me then stand
up on
your own two feet with your head held
high and say these are my values this is
where i drew the line and these are my
boundaries
and you get to do that my man you get to
do that i'm not going to bail you out
and tell you what i think you should do
but you get to do that and i'm proud of
you for making hard
choices and for it sucks for you being a
young kid put in the middle of this
trying to make your dad feel better and
trying to deal with a mom who's sick and
trying to remain loyal that's hard
but that's the rest of all of our lives
so good for you micah
i'd love to know what you decide to do
two weeks from now shoot me an email
back and we'll read it on the show here
i love to to hear back from folks when
they say hey listen i took two weeks i
took three weeks i did this and it's
been great or
i'm still struggling with something and
let's talk again so congratulations
micah good for you